c'est une vraie question mais qui n'est
pas très drôle justement parce que ça
s'est passé il n'y a pas très longtemps
c'était sur l'émission the voice voilà
amel bent qui qui est dans le jury et
samedi dernier donc une prestation a
beaucoup ému les téléspectateurs 7,2
morgan une adolescente de 16 ans qui a
choisi de réinterpréter corps dizale
pour évoquer son surpoids il inquiète
aussi en surpoids regardez cette vidéo
qui a beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup ému et
puis après on en parlera et on se dira
est ce que cette jeune fille est elle
vraiment une chance de faire carrière en
france on a tous un doute regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces auditions à la veut pour moi c'est
une opportunité de prouver que je
m'assume avec mes formes et mes rondeurs
j'ai envie que les coaches se
ressemblent comment j'ai pu souffrir et
comment je me suis relevé qu'ils
ressentent mes émotions et des
biens la réaction d'amel bent qui elle
même aussi on avait parlé avait souffert
un peu de son poids à l'époque regardez
a choisi cette chanson parce que je me
suis longtemps considéré comme un corps
et non comme une jeune fille et est du
coup j'avais envie de défendre cette
cause
c'est vrai que j'aime énormément cette
chanson parce que j'ai vécu un peu la
même histoire que toi on dirait pas
comme ça mais il ya quelques années
j'étais aussi ré malheureuse par rapport
à mon physique on vit dans une société
qui est ultra grosso faible et on a beau
être dans une dynamique de body positive
il faut les porter les kilos ça reste
quand même un combat tous les jours
c'est vrai je voulais te dire à quel
point je te trouve fortes merci à quel
point tu dois être courageuse plus que
tellement d'autres jeunes femmes de ton
âge père se voit là et merci
et avant de vous présentez vous à mes
invités ça fait beaucoup de peine ce que
je viens de voir parce que quand j'étais
assistant sur une émission de télévision
et je citerai pas parce que j'en ai
honte
amel bent venait de faire nouvelle star
et chantaient et elle avait un orage peu
en surpoids et le réalisateur que je
citerai pas non plus et la filmer et la
vidéo cadreur ne la prenait jamais par
derrière elle a un gros cul
j'étais à côté de ça je l'avais entendu
je suis très très fier des invités qu'on
a aujourd'hui elle a été demi finaliste
face à christophe willem s'est mise deux
minutes
chez lgt une heure et demie de voiture
j'ai une 106 sur les genoux cavs ont mis
sur mon pantalon c'est vrai ou pas lui
aussi est tu m'avais fait des crêpes
très gentiment et je suis très heureux
que tu sois là cyril cinélu
valider si belle voix une voix
cristalline
et olemps paulin pour ne parler que de
guise
de boue dangereuses
et ce qui est étonnant c'est que tous
les trois mais alors c'est gagnant demi
finaliste et on ne parlait que de vous
et puis derrière tout semble avoir été
un petit peu plus compliqué alors j'aime
à peut-être qu'on parle d'abord de vous
miss dominique alors aujourd'hui vous
avez perdu commune kg
70 70 kg
est ce que jouer mais voilà photos
avant/après aucun bouchon est-ce qu'il
jouerait pas couché aussi un non pas
vous perdiez pas accouché d'un enfant 70
kg non mais la grèce oui est ce que vous
pourriez me redire ce qu'on s'est dit
sur le canapé chez vous parce que ça m'a
beaucoup touché parce que ça toucherait
les gens c'est à dire que quand vous
étiez dans nouvelle star eh ben vous
m'avez dit j'ai beaucoup d'admiration
pour christophe willem mais faire gagner
une fille qui était grosse et noir
c'était juste pas envisageable c'est
vrai ou pas
c'est à dire que je pense qu'ils aillent
ya des clichés c'est vrai mais c'est je
me suis dit château de convaincre ah
ouais c'est à toi de séduire et c'est à
toi de faire en sorte que malgré tout
c'est cliché mais c'est à toi de te
faire apprécier en fait oui mais vous me
disiez lui il était beau il y avait le
petit côté un peu cliché parisien vous
me disiez pourtant chanté ensemble un
job comme par hasard souvent à la caméra
était plus sur lui ou monter un peu
monter le son de sa voix mais c'est la
vôtre c'est vrai ou pas c 6 voilà aussi
vous m'avez dit aussi tous les deux
finales mais parce que tous savent où me
l'avait dit que ça m'a marqué que je
veux que ça serve à quelque chose vous
m'avez dit on faisait chanter des
chansons me disais bon bateau adela noir
alors tu chanteras du rail afra qui nous
où tu chanteras de whitney houston qu'on
te dira pas ce que tu as on c'est
patrick on s'est vraiment dit une femme
noire
héros
voilà qu'elle envoie l'envoie pas elle
passe pas et vous m'avez même dit comme
ça j'aurai tout dit vous m'avez dit à un
moment vous chanter une chanson qui est
magnifique qui bagdad café au coin
et vous m'avez dit la prod ne voulait
pas que je gagnais monde y chantera tout
doucement avec un peu plus filet de voix
voulez pas que j'ai gagné c'est à dire
que il trouvait que sur le refrain parce
qu'elle sur l'original dans le refrain
ne l'envoie pas
l'original le monde connaît non moi pas
et moi j'en voyais justement il me
disait mais ce coup-ci ve et va falloir
que tu fasses comme pour l'original donc
tu n'en vois pas ouais et au dernier
moment j'en ai une marche et j'ai tenu
ma tête et moi du coup jaillet la ville
et bien alors que des villages touchés
je suis tout à fait à la fin des tirs
kobe chalet en bois et là le public se
l'est fixé les là le public se lève
c'est quand même incroyable et la suite
pour vous c'est quand même une victoire
de la musique
une victoire de la musique ensuite tout
s'arrête pourquoi
mais d'ailleurs je me souviens que quand
j'ai eu ma victoire est un journaliste
qui m'a suivi qui m'a dit une
déclaration et je me souviens que j'ai
dit maintenant je peux maigrir si je
veux un as ils voient ça
m'arrive mais non j'ai ça en moi j'ai eu
le disque d'or en même temps je vais
essayer vais maintenant si je veux
m'en voulez pas de dire ce conseiller
dans un salon parce que je sais que vous
vous dites pas parce que vous êtes
pudique mais moi je veux le dire pour
que les gens l'entendent et que les gens
entendent que vous m'avez dit mais même
quand je devais faire des couvertures
avec ma victoire de la musique que j'ai
vu chez vous j'étais impressionné johan
victoire de la musique il ya une
victoire de la musique me disait une
grosse qui tient une victoire de la
musique ça ne fait pas vendre
et les maisons disent qu'ils me disaient
on va pas signé chez warner ou bmg au
poids on ne signera pas une grosse c'est
ça qu'on vous a dit oui mais je reste
persuadé que quand même c'est à siamois
de convaincre arrêtez de dire ça
photo m -ca l'intention pas c'est juste
une soirée et finalement il passe outre
de trouver ensuite de montrer toute
personnalité de montrer tout ce qui
c'est normal que les gens et des a
priori il est tout le monde on a tous
des a priori mais c'est pas là malka
magazine te dit je te mettrai en une
parce que tu es grosse et pas en
amérique si c'est drôle tu n'as qu'à
scolaire que j'aime à me battre et j'ai
une question peut-être un peu con mais
miss dominique est ce que le fait
d'avoir perdu 60 kg c'est une influence
sur votre voisin vous avez perdu de la
force dans votre vrai que c'est pas du
tout non contraire la surcharge
pondérale on prenait d'énergie alors au
début ça donne un certain confort mais
pas dépasser un stade au contraire ça
sent le soufre garde fais moi un colis à
temps parce que je t'ai jebal voix
notre île pleine j'ai fait je peux te
faire une autre affaire hainard
du tout
[Musique]
tp mois comme quoi on peut être blanc et
très bien chanter oui voilà en tout cas
est ton histoire elle est très touchante
et elle est d'autant plus touchant je
peux pousser un tout petit peu ou pas
elle d'autant plus alors tout je pousse
un tout petit peu à quoi ta vie ta pas à
manger des crêpes toi tu répètes tout
voir je répète non je veux aider les
gens parce que je suis tombé fou de miss
dominique et voilà est aujourd'hui telle
vit une situation qui est difficile tu
ne vends plus disent que tu n'as plus
dead c'est compliqué pour toi de payer
son loyer tu as deux ans
je dis juste qu'aujourd'hui tu veux dire
j'ai très bien jeunes gens qu'on pas eu
la chance de se faire connaître donc
mais aussi beaucoup de gens connaissent
chance de se faire connaître et parce
qu'il n'était pas gros bas aujourd'hui
font des albums à
comparer un chien très touchante
beaucoup des rideaux mini série prévue
pour les 20 ans de la star ac'
exactement une voie que je qualifierais
ma grand mère disait de toi comme dune
et l'idée d'une voix de cristal un tabou
comme aime à citer les 20 ans des gens
m'ont dit directement oui on m'a dit bon
alors on aura les 20 ans installe dans
un mois et demi dont tu vas la salle
mais non si les ja commence déjà à
préparer non parce que c'est où
exactement je les humains mais j'entends
mais je compte je comprends pas ça comme
on peut dire ça moi mais qu'est ce que
tu as répondu qu'est ce que tu as
répondu allez vous faire [ __ ] mais non
mais non tu vas tu arrives pas répondre
ça tu vas tu es salam sall est
complètement stupide derrière tu fais un
couscous
[Rires]
et
moi je vous gage à un ami très proche
c'est dans le milieu dans le business il
m'a dit soit tu grossis tu deviens le
gros nounours noir que tout le monde va
adorer soit tu maigri tu sera vraiment
le l'étalon noir tu seras super je ne
peux pas être entre les deux il m'a dit
que je ne peux pas être entre les deux
pays mais c'est quoi entre les deux on
dit parce que un noir un noir qui est
gros mais ce combat donc ça fait rêver
parce que c'est noir sachant bien ces
grosses et gospel et du coup ça à faire
alors que si tu es tu bien foutu on va
quand tu vas chanter on sera surpris
mais c'était le choc l'école comment
t'expliquer alors comment tu expliques
que les téléspectateurs ton et lui
pardon quand tu étais rond et noir et
que les maisons de disques ne te veulent
pas rond et noir parce que pour eux je
pense que c'est un c'est un phénomène de
télévision donc star académie donc
toutes les semaines on est à la maison
on regarde on adore ah ben oui y'a cyril
qui chante c'est super cool mais à
partir du moment où passe le cap de
vainqueur et qu'il faut sortir un disque
qu'il faut faut avoir une image pour
avoir un visuel c'est génial moi je ne
pointe pas du doigt les émissions comme
the voice ou quoi mais quand c'est à
l'aveuglé c'est génial et tu sais quoi
c'est ce que m'a dit aussi miss
dominique et je rebondis là dessus on
m'a dit non mais pardon médical
christophe willem a gagné alors tout le
pari l'établissement zazie ils veulent
leur écrire des chansons mais quand et
miss dominique et que tu es un peu fort
thanh hoa d'un talent pour écrire des
chansons à la fan album de reprises et
ses chansons celles qui les a enchantés
cercle petit établissement de personnes
de chanter pour l es ce que tu aimes un
petit rire en tant que gagnant en tant
que le gagnant tu as quand même sorti un
single oui c'était un album mais ma voix
la wii un match derrière parce que bon
sinon on fait une émission complète mais
mon album est sorti un an après ma
victoire aux autres gagnants des
précédentes star academy c'était
différent oui bah parce qu'un gagnant de
la star academy lambda par exemple ce
jeu si jennifer elle a gagné la star
academy j'attends l'amour c'était déjà
en radio en une semaine deux semaines
après la prétendue longtemps
tu n'as pas eu le même traitement ban a
dû tout passe par edge et c'est
incroyable est ce que tu as des gens et
en revanche que des gens qui ont écrit
pour toi des gens capés qui ont écrit
pour toi ils ont pas du tout et non
alors moi je m'explique je suis là je
suis en
congé des vrais noms mais c'est des
vrais colère j'ai un vrai
alors même on dit bon alors déjà noir
qui gagnent la star academy ça ma chance
c'est déjà j'aurais quand même moi je
les aime bien ça revient le premier noir
à avoir gagné une émission de télé
réalité oui manche et une autre que toi
tu aimes ton millions tout de suite je
t'ai appelé on est devenu amis
exactement
on est sortis en battant sans moi ouais
gay ouais gros way we
nom m'a dit faut gommer il faut gommer
un demain jeudi bombay alors du coup
j'ai eu aucun coach vocal otago menée
par roger 50000 coach sportif un
événement ils me connaissent et me
connaissent une dizaine évasif encore
dix pompes je suis un bout de ma vie
j'ai pas envie de le faire et de voir
que c'est toujours ce qui revient mais
est ce que tu penses pas aussi que
c'était une autre époque et que
aujourd'hui pour le coup ci amène sa
gamme academy en fait on te fait faire
du coaching en disant que le corps parce
que quand on regarde la star academy on
entend des choses sur le jugement des
corps sur la façon dont on doit se
comporter tous que dans ce box dans ce
vol sont nés sur le potier positive à
yves bot tifosi timide maussire de la
mangane qu'on a vu la lumière des
évolutions comme m n'y a eu aucune
évolution que j'en repars à gagner du
temps ce que tu dis mon hugo et c'est
merveilleux cyril et moi on se connaît
depuis 20 ans c'est mon ami de vingt ans
j'ai connu au lycée c'est à dire et
cyril il a toujours eu c'est là même aux
antilles moi je l' ai connu gagnant d'un
télé crochet aux antilles est
malheureusement qu on veuille ou non la
télévision bien sûr qu'elle est grosso
fob parce qu'elle est à l'image de ce
qui la regarde en face
au site est à l'image de ses lattes et
l'exode oxydes accord la société grosso
femmes les téléspectateurs le son des
combats quelqu'un à bah oui c'est mémé
jean louis malys alors là je te
comprends pas à me plaindre je te
comprends pas c'est comme quand on dit
la france est raciste tu prends le jdd
en général les premiers c'est toujours
omar sy c'est toujours jamel nous
maintenons c'est qu'au des blacks qui on
le dit la france est raciste et là
effectivement le gagnant c'est un
gagnant qui est noir est rond et redit
la france est raciste mais parce que
la france
principe que les gros peuvent changer
d'apparence par eux mêmes c'est à dire
que oui ils peuvent maigrir télé surtout
par des principes on les tue et que
bilan de leur faute c'est de leur faute
s'ils sont
jamais avoir un troisième témoignage
parce qu'ils suivent l'inde 1 d'ailleurs
j'ai acheté mon album oui merde
[Applaudissements]
confidences nourriront finances quand je
regardais à l'époque démission ouais je
trouve très mignon
il n'y avait pas les réseaux sociaux
mais pas les réseaux sociaux préférés et
je trouvais très beau ça mais c'est très
bien je joue toujours très beau champion
très bien merci
et marié depuis six ans avec qui mais
avec julien qui m'attend c'est qu'ils se
prennent à la
cgt moi c'était comme laurentides est
marié mais pas fidèles
tu sait marier on peut être mariée avoir
un coup de coeur
olemps alors au la préhistoire à toi les
différentes bases au voc je faisais 68
kg j'ai toujours et un bassin développer
tu dis c'était dans mon adn de ma
morphologie si on m'avait dit ça serait
bien que tu perdes un peu de poids ce
que toujours charmant j'aime bien avoir
des noms même qui te dit non alors en
fait c'est pas the voice qui m'a demandé
ça moi l'émission la prod tout le monde
a toujours été très bienveillant et j'ai
trouvé ça vraiment cool on est toujours
au mit enfin voilà on fait en sorte
qu'on concentre bien après dans mon
entourage artistique mon équipe
artistique à ses proches qui m'a dit un
jour bah écoute on a des petits soucis
j'enlève mes lunettes puisqu'il s'est
fait un peu plus encore plus beau
et en fait ils m'ont dit tu vas tu sais
on a des retours des émissions c'est
trop gros ils veulent plus de toi un
objet te cacher derrière un piano c'est
à dire toujours du bien de moi oui bah
oui mais s'ils ont su
et là du coup je me dis en fait à 23 ans
tu prends ça dans la tête haute a rien
demandé surtout que je faisais à
l'époque allait j'ai un petit peu grossi
je faisais 73 kilos pour 1 mètre 75
c'est pas gros c'est pas aujourd'hui
mais qu'est ce j'aimerais bien savoir ce
qu'ils pensent de moi aujourd'hui parce
que j'ai pris du poids donc voilà je
mets tout disait ça à ce que tu peux me
dire des normes libérales et non à 12h02
pourquoi je suis pas là pour balancer
des noms ici est d'ailleurs un truc qui
est très drôle alors est ce fini mais il
n'y a pas très longtemps là qu'elle
m'a dit l'émission the voice au all-star
on a dès lors y est
alors la nation me faisait des petites
interviews présenté par alban bartoli il
me dit
tiens j'ai trouvé un truc trop cool
enfin j'ai un truc trop cool c'est une
séquence on va dire les pires et les
meilleurs tweets et là je dis ok super
allons-y c'est des tweets de 2013 et là
je vois des des noms de gens enfin des
gens que je connais qui m'ont interviewé
qu'elle est interviewé tous et qui à
l'époque écrivait le plus gros défaut
d'olympe c'est son cul oh là là et un
autre qui reçut renchérissait en disant
à bahia ça peut s'arranger mais il ya un
gros budget à prévoir une et puis après
on fait ça s'enchaîne et sa s'enchaîner
et je me suis dit mais mon dieu mais si
aujourd'hui ça sortait ces mêmes
personnes tweeté à propos de dans un
épisode de the voice aujourd'hui qu'est
ce que ce serait ce que ferait le buzz
ou est-ce que vous allez laisserait
comme ça est-ce que j'étais hors de
question j'aimerais qu'on écoute chanter
quand même parce que vous allez voir que
ce que ce que c'était colin passe de
voice
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
las pour eux ils sont
sûrs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
antonio
non seulement il est bon les craintes se
sont retournées et je veux dire quelque
chose qu'on m'avait dit à tf1 on m'avait
dit à de jolis franchement a tf1 on n'a
pas gardé bertignac la deuxième année
parce que c'est pas le plus populaire
pour les gens mais c'est le plus grand
musicien sait celui qui a la plus grande
oreille j'adore jennifer mais bertignac
c'est bertignac temps bertignac fait ça
quand tu chantes crois moi c'est comme
si hamilton te disais ça quand tu t'es
un tour d'ailleurs non mais enfin c'est
tu vas tu sais quand est-ce que je suis
gros là enfin est ce que vous trouvez
que je maigrisse fin là je te ramène
direct en soi
mais là on taime follivores mais
l'atelier z
[Applaudissements]
on est tous évidemment de base et mais
je vois pas qui est pour la grossophobie
on est tous contre la foule la
grossophobie mes soins des complètement
hypocrite faut reconnaître quand même
que quand on fait de la télévision du
cinéma de la chanson c'est un peu un
métier d'image quand même notre capital
fait partie notre corps s'est pas remis
mon cas même si je sais
coûte négocier pas fêter les maisons est
ce que j'aurais fait les implants est ce
que je me serais fait refaire les
paupières est george iny peau non je le
dis parce que je fais partie de la
métier on voulait le corps est quand
même important et j'ai fait des sacs
nous avons des sages et tonnerre je vous
donne la parole c'est intéressant ce que
tu dis parce que patrick fiori à chanter
dernièrement il est allé faire une
émission
pardon tu aimes et des cp ctc
merci et c'est vrai qu'il a pris un
petit peu de poids et dit voilà je me la
charcuterie du corps j'ai 50 ans il
s'est pris des tweets à l'humain mais
mais mais je ne sais même pas je ne sais
même pas comment on peut écrire ces gens
tombent des horreurs pareilles nicholas
taleb al alger où j'ai eu c'est une
évolution pokémon il est passé de
patrick fiori à patrick foie gras pâté
de foie gras pardon mais patrick fiori
s'est fait piquer par une abeille
patrick fiori comment il a grossi c'est
dingue
comment on peut d'abord il faut bannir
twitter à jamais mais comment on peut y
voilà il ya des choses par l'éditeur et
puis vous pardon à vous vous êtes les
premiers à faire
fitzpatrick eu récemment une tribune
photo by mater sur la plage la pauvre
elle était d'aller vais laisser
juste une chose c'est hyper important
parce que moi je pense pas que ça alors
je ne trouve pas que la télé mais ce
genre jeu nous concerne je vous explique
juste ce que je retiens c'est que les
maisons de disques ont grosso fob mais à
la télé des personnes en surpoids il y
en a quand même
marianne james ya pas longtemps qu'il a
dit linverse elle m'a dit si je perdais
du poids en fait je serai plus le
personnage que je suis devenu
leur mac était le personnage dans
camping paradis sur tf1 mais gris très
très très rond on va dire les choses
comme ça qui a fait une opération de
chirurgie pour maigrir il est devenu un
petit peu le gendre idéal et iberia
présenter danse avec les stars etc moi à
l'époque je travaillais à france
dimanche en recevaient des courriers de
lecteurs qui nous dit on le reconnaît
plus rendez-nous laurent ournac c'est
plus le même temps mais ça fait des
lecteurs à la con mais adil dominique
nato helicopter n'apparaissent que vous
regrettez d'avoir perdu vos 70 kg a dit
non pas du tout a dit est ce que vous
pensez de ça un impact c'est à ce que
vous pensez que les gens aujourd'hui
aimerait - voir miss dominique sur scène
parce qu'ils ont pu là la base la mama
miss dominique qui qu'ils aimaient à la
r je ne regrette pas mais les gens
roccat assez bref les gens mais
est-ce que c'est un petit d'une heure
est ce que si un producteur vous disais
miss dominique reprend 40 kg et tu fais
trop de la tat d'après temps maintenant
mais par contre les gens peuvent souvent
me dit je te préférait qu'on est bien su
saisir les sages
les avoir une croix pour eux l'espoir je
portais 7 c'est pour pc wii 2 ils ont
l'impression que j'ai retourné ma veste
que je les ai trahis a trahi les
personnes s'étant inscrits mais il ne
peut pas empêcher déjà leurs bases
ennemies ne sera absolument pas compte
qu'ici maigri aussi c'est parfois parce
qu'ils sont en obésité morbide c'était
le même laurent ournac life et les
otages mais que vous étiez beaucoup plus
sympathique quand vous étiez plus gros
il avait pas le choix il fallait qui
maigrissent et les médecins qui les boss
lui derrière un sonia dubois souvient
froufrous de bien serrer la main du 70
kg bon ba aujourd'hui les cas la cuisine
dans sa cuisine voilà et mais prenez les
comédiennes donc pas mais le nahd vers
lola dewaere le nombre de fois où les
réviseurs de la fille de maastricht
disque mais pas du tout on mérite perdre
30 kg et tu verras tu auras le nombre et
les acteurs que l'on dit son petit
maigri et elle a toujours répondu ce que
tu as dit dominick guinn vie mais non je
maigris ray quand je leur ai choisi moi
et pas parce que vous me posez pour un
euro et à vraiment maintenant aussi
celle ci comme comme isabelle adjani
elle est venue mais roland m'a dit il
faut que tu maigri et on leur demande de
maigrir en un temps record résultat
pendant 40 à elles font le yo-yo +20 -30
plus maintenant alors lorient j'avais
posé une question à florian à lorient
honnêtement toi qui fais d une de closer
et tu vois ce qui se vend à ce qui se
voit pas quand tu mets en une une
personne qui est forte ronde est ce que
ça se vend alors franchement c'est
absolument pas comme ça qu'on calcule
parce qu'en fait en fait on peut prendre
le problème à l'envers c'est que il ya
peut-être peu de personnes qui sont au
standing des gens qu'on peut mettre en
une danse et canards la de je parle de
personnes en surpoids je peux répondre
comme ça je peux pas dire parce qu'il
est en surpoids y laissera pas quelqu'un
qui a une énorme star en surpoids bah
oui sera en une de closer de voici le
taux de l'iso par exemple à 10 c'est ça
adèle sa carrière elle s'arrêter que
telle ait perdu du poids
lambert
aurait-on dit tu dis n'importe quoi ne
me reprend jamais toi dans l'oreillette
c'est une star française qui est en
surpoids qui se met à thouars quai comme
l'iso sur son instinct g je suis pas sûr
que ça plaise à tout le monde en france
et que rares compte tout le monde adore
l'iso elle est tout le temps en train de
thouars qu'est star américaine en
surpoids il c'est génial c'est la
question à vous deux du coup pareil on
vous dit demain reprend 30 qu'ils ont eu
le dessus et vous faites moi je vis je
veux tu manges quand je lui en fais rien
à foot pardon
je mange quand je veux c'est à dire que
quand j'arrive chez moi je ferme la
porte voix dans mon lit je suis tout
seul avec mes peines mes joies
maintenant j'arrête c'est déjà les trucs
il faut maigrir parce que si tu mets
grippe a ils vont dire que c'est un à
aucun moment on m'a toujours dit on s'en
fout tu sens bien on le sait c'est bon
c'est pas le problème de la voie n'est
plus le problème c'est le visuel que je
sais que tu sais tu sais ce qui m'a ce
qui m'a fait la peine moi c'est que
quand j'ai vu miss dominique s'est elle
encore une fois avec ses crêpes tâche
est
énorme et il était à bercy on est resté
deux heures et pendant l'été quand il
parle quand je t'ai parlé j'étais bien
dans l'émission tout ça tout ça tu m'as
dit et moi j'y viens je parle de tout ce
que tu veux mais tu m'as dit la chanson
c'est fini c'est vrai ça cib est alors
et pour moi mais parce que je pense
qu'elle est également blessé six depuis
quand c'est moi qui décide a b c soit
[Musique]
moi je me souviens très bien tu l'as des
connards décidé pour toi quand je suis
quand je suis arrivé chez sony et que
j'ai commencé à collaborer avec m6 ils
m'ont dit on a crié et si on veut en
tout détruire c'est comme ça
d'une émission du lit si on veut que
quelqu'un réussisse on lui voulait pas
et quand on a décidé qu'elle a fait le
job qu'on a plus besoin on lui ferme et
oui certains c'est ça l'idée parce que
on dit beaucoup de choses si j'ai décidé
puisque là c'est pas moi qui la met à
l'air dégoûté bon l air dégoûté mais
c'est normal qu'ils écoutent c'est le
métier qui veut ça la raison elle
rappelle juste de les règles et ça
marche pour un gros ça marche pour un
mec ça marche pour n'importe qui ce que
milla ce que j'annonce et aux écoutes
qui auraient été en surpoids etc ont
raté la première marche du podium mais
regarde tous les numéro 2 de tous et de
ses talents de show il ya plein de
maigres mais moi ils sont pas connues
c'est ce que je veux dire c'est qu'à
demander non laurence boccolini valérie
damidot que je vois à la télé grosso fob
pardon laurent fontaine g et à leurs
petits gros
jean pierre coffe d'antan bernard menez
cauet marois la chanson laissez moi
finir personne n'a jamais dit par
exemple quand j'ai produit connaît pour
la première fois il a pas de cheveux qui
ressemble à un bout chez picard s'il est
un peu gros mais rebecca écoute et vous
mes chers c'est l'écouté vous
écouter vous les amis mais personne
n'avait fait aucune réflexion 20 ans
aux états unis pas bon la plus grande
et ouais je ferai la plus grande et des
animateurs télé sally fitzgibbons
mangin début la deuxième truc j'aimerais
dire c'est que pardon ça fait 40 ans que
j'ai des problèmes de poids et que je
suis en permanence on ne pas boucher ou
de faire attention ça dure six semaines
huit semaines j'ai écrit de 10 kg je
reprends et xsara mais quels mots
auxquels personne en surpoids a envie de
rester comme elle est pardon sud acadie
et posons aussi la vraie question est ce
que c'est aussi bien de montrer en
permanence des gens énorme dont on sait
qu'ils sont psychologiquement pas si
bien que ça
[Applaudissements]
gameiro c'est un passe temps on pressent
pour ma paroisse qui toi et toi
s'écoute pourquoi elle a perdu 70 kg
alors mais j'parle berne qu'on s'en
aperçoive et wade pas toi tu arrives à
des mignons comme tout mais pourquoi on
demande de perdre du poids mais tend à
faire du camp même s'ils restent alors
on maison mais on n'est pas dans la même
case des gens qui sont en surpoids qui
sont pas mais moi je suis une sorte que
mes potes et non une discussion serrée
alors serré ma série là où je te
reconnais - c'est qu'effectivement ce
mois là bas pourquoi dis moi peine un
bébé ce que j'ai à prades à ses
ingénieurs parce que je le connais on se
connaît très bien je viens par là c'est
qu'effectivement là où je rejoins
laurent tout ce que j'avais entendu à
l'antenne sonia dubois tous les laisser
nous est rond et de grenades ou c'est
vivre et où dix ans après ils ont fait
un régime tout perdu 70 kg ils ont écrit
un bouquin tu
es ce que tu connais une personne du
soir on est heureuses et tu sais que moi
un chanteur s'était moins chanteur j'ai
entendu laurence boccolini j'entends du
dtm présentateur
aux etats unis c'est encore l'avenir au
saint jean non mais là où il a raison
c'était moi un chanteur français on va
dire gros pardon resté clément à la con
citez moi un seul auteur gros français
carlos c'est un bisou de nice russes ont
fait un bond en avant une finale ici
aujourd'hui c'est à dire vivant comme
quelque chose bien sûr que je pense
c'est que c'est pas la grosseur qui gêne
c'est le changement mais oui c'est le
changement était arrivée gros c'est ça
reste une exacte par mois seraient les
gros doigts tout en nous
[Applaudissements]
tout le monde tu n'es plus sévères
qu'avant qu'on avance un bilan sera pas
un moment de douceur parce que je crois
qu'on a entendu chanter tout le monde
sauf sauf cyril cyril l'oin cyril c'est
la voix de cristal en séries c'est mon
ami cyril c'est un chanteur ouais cyril
c'était sale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
oui dans l'oreillette est la plus belle
n'a pas entendu chanteur
les accords
[Musique]
es tu
d'amour
e
gillet
[Musique]
et
m e
j'irai jusqu'au bout du monde
je me ferai un boulot
c'est une folle le monde
[Musique]
recevra tous mais j'aimerais vous dire
quelque chose deborah qui est ici et qui
est une bombe intégral est une ancienne
obèse c'est vrai c'était j'étais très
très forte j'ai perdu 30 petits bouts en
laisse par my godness
en l'espace d'un an et quelques way et
il ya un truc qui est top c'est le body
positive et ça je suis pour à 1000% que
les gens s'assume et cetera mais on a le
droit aussi de pas se sentir bien dans
sa peau quand on est comme comme j'étais
là et d'avoir envie on a la chance de
pouvoir se faire opérer quand on peut se
faire opérer grâce à ça j'ai perdu 30
kilos et je suis hyper contente et je ne
suis pas du tout passé de l'autre côté
justin j'ai plein de copines qui était
comme moi un peu forte à l'époque qui
nous assaillent et tu nous a lâché et
est passé de l'autre côté moi là-bas
pour terminer c'est vous dire je veux
qu'on ait de miss dominique je vais
t'aider je te le promets et pour le
reste écoutez moi bien fuck the maison
de disques à samedi prochain et lundi
c'est fait merci
[Applaudissements]